this is ami tacular land of zombies guns
an awesome return funny that's what I
called it back in the day the zombie
tacular land of zombies guns are the
genesis of awesome tacular apparently I
just take a word and put tacular at the
end and just becomes a better version of
the word in my mind's eye also if this
is too much blue apologies but we have a
trailer for zombie land double tap which
for those of you don't know what double
tapping is it's just shooting someone
twice ten years after zombie land holy
[ __ ] time flies so Oh zombie lands ten
years old Daniel Radcliffe's thirty also
do not look this movie up on IMDB I went
there saw something that might be
construed as a spoiler so don't do it
just warning you might not even be real
it's not like IMDB is like super legit
the things fall through the cracks on
IMDB all the time might be [ __ ] but
in case it's real don't go there which
is funny because someone sent me a link
and they were like it's the sequel no
one was really asking for it to be fair
people were asking for zombie land too
when zombie land came out ten years ago
Grenda this movie probably would have
done well for herself if it came out
back when you know people gave a [ __ ]
about The Walking Dead maybe they were
like good it's gonna get buried under
Marvel [ __ ]
now that the Avengers arc has wrapped up
with Thanos and everything now will come
out I don't know I do like how the
beginning of this trailer it shows the
credentials
it's like nominated nominated nominated
winner it's like when Zombieland came
out it was like Woody Harrelson and a
bunch of newbies like Woody Harrelson
and Abigail Breslin and a couple of
movies point is in the course of the
past decade between Zombieland 1 and now
the cast has put in some time and really
in this trailer what we know is it's
zombie lands in Washington DC it's post
zombie apocalypse Washington DC yeah
they're probably gonna get political I
mean come on they're totally gonna have
political jokes just brace for it but
also I know if the zombie apocalypse
happened I'd be the first place I go one
thing I know for certain is I would go
to the Oval Office never just try to sit
in that chair I think that would amaze
me I'm fine president but regardless of
the time gap I think zombie land the
world of zombie land is interesting
enough to revisit five years later 10
years later 20 years later everything is
a neat world I like zombie apocalypse
comedy but dark comedy action comedy but
also it has to be done well there is
that I think we can do a lot of fun
stuff with zombie land too especially
the fact that it's 10 years later so god
this crews been around for a while
there's straight-up a family
stay meat a variant of their crew I
don't like you at all
I think you double-parked one more
perpendicular parks hope we don't get it
is going on here
wait something you know how that's gonna
go down though it's like they're so
similar they hate each other and it
might just be a cameo who knows it might
not even be an actual arc in the movie
might just be this one thing that
happens in the movie and it's just one
funny moment they lurk that would be
great in a trailer funny thing I do
notice is this have nothing against it
be SOT just wanna beat the [ __ ] out what
makes that funny is that that sentiment
is also in once upon a time in Hollywood
it's like is Hollywood trying to get
back at demographic they spent the last
few years you know alienating let me
last for years it's always been like we
hate right-wing tallahassee types i
should't entire demographic just hates
us now we hate hippies they're hippies
don't forget it'll be fine I don't know
but I wouldn't put it past Hollywood
Hollywood in their calculated moves but
I'm looking forward to saw me double tap
I really enjoyed zombie land it was like
one of those the first one was one of
those trailers I worked in the theater
at the time I was like I hope that's
good it turned out I really liked it
Bill Murray gets to set the record
straight does not like the fact that he
was in Garfield it's done by the same
director so I'm hoping he knows what
he's doing I hope he spent the last 10
years ago no I want to make Zombieland
too perfect not just though I have
nothing else to do I'll write the script
in a week and a half last week I don't
know but we'll see but Zombieland double
tab have you seen the trailer what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]